I'm sure yesterday you heard that the
Supreme Court ruled in favor of Jack
Phillips the Christian Baker at
masterpiece cake shop in Colorado who
refused to make a cake for a gay wedding
they ruled in favor of him it was a big
victory for for him Jack Phillips
specifically personally which is great
because he's a good and decent man he
was being persecuted by this government
agency that the Supreme Court determined
the government agency being the Colorado
Civil Rights Commission Supreme Court
determined that they were just openly
hostile and and and prejudiced against
Jack Phillips and so that's essentially
what the Supreme Court decided that he
personally was being victimized by this
government agency that could not
disguise its contempt for Phillips and
his religious beliefs as far as the
broader questions of the First Amendment
and religious liberty they sort of left
that alone it didn't touch it
so that's its I don't think we get the
big victory for religious liberty that
we wanted although we could still
celebrate that this this this this man
would have been unfairly targeted has
been vindicated and this government
agency has been rebuked by the supreme
court and humiliated and embarrassed so
that's that's good that's justice and we
can also celebrate the fact that the
other set of bullies in this case that
being the gay couple themselves they
also lost and have now been humiliated
in front of the world
which is what they richly deserve
because they really
their behavior in this case has been
just utterly despicable
just awful
and let's start with the fact that the
gay couple very clearly targeted Jack
Phillips because of his religious
beliefs I simply don't believe that in a
in a state in in one of the most gay
friendly most liberal states in the
Union where there are hundreds of
bakeries and other stores to choose from
where you might find a wedding cake I
don't believe that they just so happened
coincidentally to walk in the door of
the one bakery in the whole state run by
a guy who was so Orthodox and
conservative in his Christian faith that
he won't even make Halloween cakes I
don't believe that's a coincidence
and if I were inclined to believe that
it is a coincidence it would become
clear that it's not coincidental when
you look at how they reacted what their
response was
when Jack Phillips explained that he
could not make them a customized gay
wedding cake
after being told that you know they
could have responded a number of
different ways they could have said okay
you won't make a customized cake I
understand that I respect your beliefs
so instead we'll just buy a regular
wedding cake and we'll customize it
ourselves or we'll get someone else to
decorate it whatever they could have
done that or they could have done it
would probably be the most logical thing
to do and that is to just leave the
store and go somewhere else go anywhere
else and if they really feel personally
offended then there they'd be perfectly
free to tell their friends that Jack
Phillips at masterpiece cake shop won't
make gay weddings because he disapproves
of gay marriage
and you know they'd be perfectly free to
do that
that would also be reasonable
but they didn't choose either of those
options either up a decent reasonable
person would choose either option
but these are in decent people
these are bullies
option three and that is they responded
to Jack Phillips not making a cake they
responded to that by embarking on a
five-year mission to ruin his business
destroy him personally and impoverished
his family
that's how they responded
he said oh I'm sorry I can't make that
cake they said ok I'm going to ruin your
life and they lost
and that's a that's a that's a great
thing but we have to be prepared for the
fact that the fascist bullies on the
left and in the gay lobby they're gonna
come back and try it again there they
might not try it again with Jack
Phillips after they just lost that but I
think in fact they're going to double
their efforts now to punish Christian
business owners for being Christian and
you're gonna find even more Christian
business owners targeted first because
of for retribution and you know the gay
lobby is very vengeful
very spiteful hateful and Benj Vil
on the rare occasion that they suffer a
loss they're going to find they're gonna
make you pay for it that's very clear so
that's what's gonna happen here out of
vengeance and also because they want the
Supreme Court to basically overturn the
First Amendment that's the that's the
result they were looking for they wanted
the Supreme Court to come out and say to
Christian business owners you do not
have the right to decide how you do
business and who you do business with
you don't have the right to decide that
you don't want to participate in or
promote or celebrate an event that you
find morally problematic so they were
looking for the the overturning of the
First Amendment and they're going to
keep going at it until until they
achieve that that result
so
I think that means that we can't just
you know rest on our laurels here and
kick back and say well this is over it's
done because it's not
and that's why I think it's important to
make very clear what exactly as
Christians and conservatives as
constitutionalist as people who believe
in freedom we need to make clear what
our point is exactly when it comes to
these kinds of cases
and
so that's why we have to stipulate
because there seems to be a lot of
confusion in this regard
this is not a question of whether or not
a business owner has the right to refuse
service to anybody that's not the
question in this case now personally I
happen to believe that a business owner
should have that right to refuse service
to anyone I think that's the simplest
answer
your business owner you own the building
you own the business
it's your labor it's your product it's
your service you get to decide who can
take part in this who can purchase it
and who can't
and you should be able to refuse service
to anyone even for awful and racist
reasons
that's how it should be now that's not
how the laws in our country are actually
written right now as the laws are
currently written you don't have the
right to refuse service to anyone and
you don't have the right to discriminate
based on who somebody is
even if I think that you should have
that right now and III
no of course what people will say is
well what if a business owner refuses
service to somebody because they're
black
I think that would be morally wrong for
a business owner to do that it would
also be financially suicidal but yes I
think you should have that right
and if the government were to come out
tomorrow and declare to all business
owners hey you guys can do what you want
refuse service to anybody if they were
to say that
I don't think you're gonna have hundreds
of businesses who say Oh finally now we
can discriminate against black people
like we've always wanted to do no I
don't think it's God I mean and if you
did have like two or three businesses in
the entire country that said okay we're
gonna be segregated based on race now
fine let them come out and announce that
policy and their businesses will be well
they'll be out of business by the next
day I mean I give them about a 24 hour
life span because they're gonna lose all
only the most dedicated and hardcore
racists would would still patronize a
business like that and there just aren't
enough people like that to keep a
business going so yeah you know what
this is how I feel about it
if there is a in in my local community
if there's a business owner out there
who is so brimming with racism
that he would deny service to black
people if given the ability to do so I
say yes let him come out and announce
himself let him expose himself so that I
can stop giving him my money
if like a coffee shop down the street is
run by a despicable horrible racist I
prefer it if he announced it to everyone
so that I can stop going there and
giving him my money
anyway these are all interesting
questions but they're actually
irrelevant to the masterpiece cake shop
case or to any of these Christian
business on our cakes cases you know
when it comes to to gay weddings and so
forth
they're actually completely irrelevant
because the question
is not
whether it's not a question of can a
business owner refuse service to someone
based on who they are
the question is can a business owner
refuse to participate in or promote or
celebrate an event
that they think is morally wrong
so Jack Phillips he did not refuse
service to gay people he refused service
to a gay wedding
Mullins and Craig the gay couple they
could have bought anything in the store
they could have bought 50 they could
they could have bought 50 wedding cakes
if they wanted to they could have bought
every cupcake and brownie and cookie in
the store if they wanted to he did not
say to them Oh get out of here we don't
serve your kind they could have bought
anything he did not refuse service to
them based on who they were that's not
what happened
he simply said I cannot participate in
this particular event
now if you want to buy a cake that
you're gonna just go home and eat
yourself or you want to buy a birthday
cake you want to buy a cake for anything
whatever you want it just you can have
it I just cannot make a special
customized cake for a gay wedding that's
what I can't do
it's relevant to note that Jack Phillips
in the past had had many times in the
past refused to make customized cakes
for events that he thought were were
morally problematic he refused to make
Halloween cakes as I mentioned he
refused to make lewd bachelor party
cakes he now this is real this is this
is an important point he refused to make
cakes for divorce parties now we happen
to live in a society unfortunately where
divorce parties are a thing where a
couple gets divorced and sometimes
they'll throw a party kind of kind of
like a they'll throw a a anti wedding
reception or an unwitting reception or
something where they'll they'll go out
and they'll get a wedding style cake but
they'll customize it and decorate it
specially for divorce and then they'll
celebrate their divorce now it just so
happens that that a few years ago a guy
went into masterpiece cake shop and he
asked for a for a for a divorce party
cake he wanted a wedding cake that was
split in half and decorated specially
for divorce and Jack Phillips refused
him Jack Phillips said I can't make that
cake now does that mean that Phillips
was refusing to serve a divorced person
or was he refusing to make something for
a divorce party
distinction here is very clear
he'll serve anyone who's divorced he'll
serve any gay person
he just can't make a cake for this
specific event
why is that
because when you're a master baker like
Jack Phillips when you're you know when
you're a brilliant Baker when you when
this is your craft this is what you do
for a living
then for you cake is a work of art
now you and I would mean we make a cake
from like a mix from a box or something
that we bought from from the grocery
store that's not a work of art for us
but for Jack Phillips it's a work of art
it's art
him to make a piece of art
that is specially designed to celebrate
a certain kind of occasion
while in his mind he can't do that
and use his creative powers to make this
thing to celebrate an occasion if he
thinks that the occasion itself is is
morally disordered
and that makes a lot of sense of course
he needs to have that right as a
business owned
now we can ask the question was he right
for refusing to make this cake I think
he was but who cares what I think who
cares what you think
this is his labor this is his creative
energy he should have the right to
decide how he expends it and to what end
so the precedent that the court could
set
but did
the precedent they could have said I
think is really clear and it's a
precedent that would give rights and
freedoms to guys like Jack Phillips but
would not allow a business owner to
refuse service to someone based on their
race no there is it is possible to draw
a line there of distinction even though
I happen to think that the easiest and
simplest and most correct thing is just
to give business owners the right to
refuse service to anyone that we don't
even really need to go that far
um what the Supreme Court could say is
you can refuse to participate in or
promote or celebrate or provide a good
or service to an event or activity that
contradicts your moral or religious
beliefs
so a black person
who just wants to go in and buy a cake
to refuse service to hit to him that
doesn't that doesn't qualify that
doesn't fall under the parameters here
and that also doesn't really fall under
the parameters of the First Amendment
and if a gay person walked in the store
and wanted to buy something and you said
no I know I'm not gonna serve you
because you're gay and I hate gay people
that doesn't fall under the parameters
and that also isn't really covered by
the First Amendment
but if a person comes in no matter who
they are and they say hey I've got this
event coming up and I want and I know
it's it's and I want to celebrate the
event and I want you to make something
special for that event well then a
business owner has the right to decide
whether or not that's the kind of event
they want to be involved in whether it's
the kind of event that they want to
dedicate their labor and their creative
energies to celebrate
so as these as this controversy
continues and we see more and more cases
like this it's really important for
those of us who understand what these
cases are really about it's very
important for us to correct people any
time you hear someone say oh it's you
know they just want to refuse service to
gay people wrong that is completely
false that is not what this is about
we are simply saying that a business
owner has the right
to discriminate against
certain events not people events
occasions activities
and I think on
level we all must agree with that
now you might not think that that a is
that a gay wedding should be one of
those occasions but I'm short just to
use a classic example that people like
to use I'm sure you would agree that if
you had a a black business owner or
really any kind of business owner of any
race and somebody walks in from the Klan
and says we're throwing a big bash for
the 70th anniversary of our clan chapter
and we want you to make a special cake
for that occasion the business owner
should have the right to say no I'm not
gonna make a cake for that because I
happen to think that that event is
morally wrong and terrible and I don't
want to be involved in it in any way
shape or form
so we all believe that there are lines
that are drawn
which means that we have to give
business owners the power and the right
and the ability to make these
determinations that's
very simple distinction here and I don't
know why people struggle to understand
it although I think maybe people don't
struggle to understand it they just
pretend but they don't understand
thanks for listening thanks for watching
Godspeed everybody